bonjour bonjour quatre jours merveilleux
tu as l'air en forme mais merci de me
laisser faire bon d'introduction mais tu
comprends pas on va parler du 15e siècle
aujourd'hui c'est ma période
enfin je vois un épisode sur le 19e
siècle et rien ne va plus et bien sage
qu'on ne va pas parler que du 15e siècle
aujourd'hui mais qu'on ira du 15e au 17e
siècle et que je pourrais très bien
refaire des épisodes sur le 19e voire
même sur l'antiquité si ça me chante et
que si ça ne te plaît pas tu peux aussi
rentrer chez toi
bienvenue dans cet épisode sur la chasse
aux sorcières et mais c'est pas grave ça
[Musique]
cette vidéo peut très bien se regarder
toute seule mais elle vient conclure une
trilogie que j'ai lancée sur la
sorcellerie dans mon épisode 12 sur
l'acquisition j'avais déjà abordé les
procès de sorcellerie du point de vue
des inquisiteurs et de la manière dont
ils mener leur procès et dans mon
épisode 2d créatrice du tube j'ai
présenté l'imaginaire du sabar avec
plein de jolies images
terminons donc ce triptyque des
sorcières avec du lourd
la chasse aux sorcières où se déroulait
tels qu'ils étaient ces femmes et
pourquoi pourquoi un truc pareil at il
eu d'existence des sorcières et reconnu
par l'église par la bulle soumises des
idées rente est affective bouche de 1484
avant ça les sorcières avait déjà été
mentionné par saint-augustin au 9e
siècle et par des théologiens du 14e
siècle qui réfléchissait au comportement
hérétiques lesquels tolérer lesquels
condamné s'il y avait un démon dans
l'histoire globalement se tait condamné
en 1486 et rédigé le célèbre mall et
ousmane sy fy quarouble marteau des
sorcières par deux inquisiteur allemand
qui explique ce que sont les sorcières
pourquoi ce sont majoritairement des
femmes
le tout afin de justifier l'acquisition
menée par leurs collègues et eux mêmes
c'est un grand succès littéraire tirée à
30 mille exemplaires même si en cette
fin du xvème siècle les persécutions
envers les sorcières reste plutôt faible
elle commence doucement à partir du
xvième siècle en effet à la fin du xvème
siècle les procès de sorcellerie ne
concerne qu environ 50 cas par an et par
pays on les retrouve surtout en suisse
et en savoie et à la frontière entre la
france et la germanie ce qui s'explique
par le climat religieux assez tendue à
cette époque
depuis cette époque là on accuse juste
les sorcières de maléfique um
c'est-à-dire de pratiques magiques on
parle pas encore de sorcellerie
démoniaque
durant les deux premiers tiers du 16e
siècle les procès reste faible les
ouvrages comme le mali ousmane sy fy
caroulle ne sont pas réédité et à ce
moment là la mode est à la poursuite des
bouteurs de peste des petits malins qui
s'amusent à répondre la peste des lois
apparaissent toutefois à l'encontre de
la sorcellerie en 1532 charles quint
créé pour les pays bas la constitution
criminaliste caroline qui réglemente les
pratiques de la magie et de la
sorcellerie
d'autres lois répressives apparaissent
en europe à mesure que des traité de
théologie sont rédigées parce que 2580
ça redémarre
en france le magistrat jean bodin écrit
un traité qui expliquent le déroulement
du sabbat les crimes des sorcières et en
tout en europe une trentaine de traiter
sont rédigées par des théologiens pour
la plupart mais aussi par exemple par le
roi de l'ecosse figeac 6 dans la vision
du 16e siècle
la chasse aux sorcières est un moyen de
renforcer le pouvoir royal puisqu'elle
va à l'encontre de satan se sagouin qui
pousse les femmes à renverser l'ordre
les procès commence donc en écosse vers
1590 dans l' empire germanique et en
scandinavie au début du xviie siècle
il existe des épicentres de la chasse
aux sorcières la suisse la france les
pays bas et l empire germanique mais on
retrouve aussi des procès en autriche en
belgique en estonie niveau ni au
danemark en finlande en hongrie en
islande au luxembourg en norvège en
pologne et en suède
al'inverse les pays où on en retrouve
très peu sont l'italie où il ne donne
pas lieu à des exécutions
le portugal la russie et l'espagne on a
souvent le stéréotype de femmes vieille
marginal qui porterait la marque du
diable pratiquerait le sabbat et
danserait des sorts à l'encontre des
hommes et des bêtes
forcément les sorcières sont vieilles ce
que les vieilles c'est hyper mystérieux
et puis les vieilles ça fait penser à la
mort et donc au diable par extension non
mais où sont les pires il ya que vous
que ça fait fantasmer les lieux dans la
réalité
qui sont ces personnes pour la plupart
ce sont bien des femmes puisqu'elles
représentent environ 80% des personnes
jugées les autres étant des hommes et
des enfants
on trouve une exception en russie en
finlande et en estonie où le taux de
femmes n'est que d'environ 40 à 50%
vive la parité pour ce qui est de leur
situation elles sont majoritairement
issus de la population rurale puisque
80% des sorcières sont des paysannes les
villes sont très peu concernés par la
chasse aux sorcières et de la pratique
qu occasionnellement par exemple on a
des procès à aix en provence en 1611 la
plupart sont mariés sur 100 cas en
franche comté de 1434 à 1667 on compte
17 9 27 célibataire et 56 femmes marie
pourquoi ces femmes étaient à l'accusé
bien la plupart du temps elles étaient
dénoncées par leurs proches ou par leurs
propres enfants
il y a eu des cas d'enfants sorciers en
europe mais la plupart du temps ceux-ci
jouer un rôle de dénonciateur accusant
leurs parents ou leurs mamies en 1611
dans la région du lac si jeanne au nord
de stockholm
ce sont des enfants âgés de 5 à 9 ans
qui accusent leurs familles de
participer au sabbat attendait une fois
ma mère m'a dit si tu es passage avec
tes parents tu iras pas à la saint jean
magie et penser un petit accusations
j'aurais pu faire la fête tranquille
parfois les paysans se lancer eux mêmes
dans la chasse aux sorcières dans des
épisodes de panique où tout le monde
centre accusés c'est ainsi qu à logrono
en espagne en 1610 ont lieu six
exécutions pour sorcellerie
suite à ça c'est la grosse psychose tout
le monde accuse tout le monde des
paysans torture eux-mêmes les suspects
au final 1777 personnes sont accusées
dont 1384 enfants les jusque là cela
faire en disant que la sorcellerie
disparaîtra si on arrête d'en faire la
publicité merci bien bonsoir c'est vrai
que dans les campagnes c'était un peu la
psychose parfois il y avait une histoire
de philippe de vigneulles qui raconte
ceci un prêcheur arrive dans un village
il demande à tout le monde de baisers
les reliques lui se transporter sauf les
sorciers et sorcières et leur interdit
du coup tout le monde s'empresse de le
faire de peur d'être accusés de
sorcellerie
ils sont cons ces vis des joueurs
parfois à des catastrophes naturelles
comme des épisodes de peste ou de famine
accélère les procès de sorcellerie
mais dans la plupart des cas ces procès
ont lieu en temps de paix
en temps de guerre les juges ont un
petit peu plus peur d'aller se balader
entre les villages pour faire leur
procès durant les procès comme les
accusés sont souvent des pauvres pécore
elle n'ose pas trop la ramener les
procès verbaux de sorcellerie nous
montre qu'on leur posait des questions
souvent très détaillée très personnelles
tirées des ouvrages de démonologie et de
ce qu'avaient dit les témoins on pouvait
parfois confrontés les accusés avec les
témoins torturait les accusés recherché
sur elle la marque du diable
au début leur réponse était souvent
assez laconique elle répondait par oui
ou par non
et dès l'instant où elle lâché
psychologiquement leurs réponses
devenait très détaillée allant forcément
dans le sens de ce que voulaient les
juges
les accusés avaient aussi intérêt à
rester docile parce qu'elles pouvaient
ainsi espérer un rite aid to mme l sont
toujours condamné au bûcher
mais le bourreau les étrangle
discrètement dès que les flammes sont
assez haute pour le cachet très généreux
des accusés pouvaient aussi craindre
d'être des sorcières sans le savoir et
beaucoup parlé immédiatement ou tenté de
se suicider pour éviter la
arthur les procès visait aussi à trouver
les complices et là c'était l'hécatombe
en 1597 par exemple une condamnée accusa
m seuls 19 autres personnes
le club de sorcellerie de son village
devait être costaud le plus glauque dans
l'histoire est que la plupart des
dénonciations faites par des condamnés
concernés la famille on entraîne donc au
bûcher avec soin ses parents ses enfants
ses frères et soeurs saison oncles ses
tantes en 1610 une sorcière de bromont
âgé de 9 ans entraîne avec elle son père
sa mère ses grands-parents ses oncles et
ses tantes de deux choses soit il
l'avait dénoncé soit ils n'ont rien fait
pour l'aider dans les deux cas ça craint
au final ces procès avait pour but de
diffuser l'obéissance dans les domaines
de la sexualité la morale la famille et
au début du xviie siècle pas question de
remettre en cause la chasse aux
sorcières sous peine d'être poursuivi
soi même on estime qu'en europe il y a
eu entre 60000 et 100000 bûcher de
sorcières
d'autres chiffres d'être 18 19e siècle
évoque 500000 sorcières mais là c'est un
peu exagéré
entre 30 et 50% des personnes jugées ont
été exécutés des autres ceux qui par
exemple n'avoir rien ou pour lesquels il
n'y avait pas de preuves étaient pour la
plupart banny et là il s'est posé à
d'autres procès ailleurs parce que la
vie de banny était loin d'être facile
à partir des années 1650 ça commence à
se calmer certains magistrats commencent
à refuser de condamner à mort pour
sorcellerie
disons que les femmes accusés sont
peut-être folk il faudrait plutôt les
traiter en plus l'image de la sorcière
dans la littérature et des cônes au
graffiti devient un peu plus sympa les
intellectuels joue aussi un rôle dans
cette évolution
montaigne des cartes dénonce la chasse
aux sorcières en y opposant le principe
de rationalité cyrano de bergerac
déclarent ne pas croire aux sorcières
tout court en 1671 jacques d'autun
dénonce l'attitude des magistrats dans
l'incrédulité savantes et la crédulité
ignorante au sujet des magiciens et
sorciers ce titre claque et il est
possible que ce livre est amené à faire
réfléchir les magistrats en question les
magistrats du parlement de paris se met
à casser en appel des sentences
prononcées dans les provinces et louis
xiv intervient en 1670 il interdit au
parlement de pau bordeaux et rouen de
mener des procès de sorcellerie et avec
les 10
1682 la sorcellerie est officiellement
décriminalisée en france enfin bien sûr
les milieux ruraux continue de croire à
la sorcellerie comme les croyait déjà
avant xvème siècle mais il ya plus
poursuites pourquoi at-on chasser les
sorcières plusieurs visions et
explications se sont succédé au fil du
temps à l'époque des chasses aux
sorcières ont favorisé la thèse des
monos logique comme quoi les fans
c'était le mal parce que pactiser avec
le diable et cetera commence à connaître
surtout les vieilles arrête avec les
vieilles pourtant la démonologie n'est
pas abordée dans tous les procès en
hollande en landes et en angleterre on y
fait très peu mention de plus les
témoignages reprennent très polémique du
sabbat et du démon mais plutôt la magie
villageoise
par exemple les maléfices qui vise les
hommes les bêtes ou les récoltes le
diable c'était surtout le délire des
inquisiteurs dans leurs traités mais
comme les pécores savez pas lire çà leur
passé un peu au-dessus dans les
témoignages de personnes qui ont dénoncé
des sorcières on retrouve donc de la
divination des talismans protecteur des
méthodes de guérison pas très catholique
la mort de personne et de bêtes c'est à
dire tout ce qui forme et la
superstition au moyen-âge à cette époque
d'ailleurs à partir du xviie siècle
l'église essaye de remettre la main sur
ces superstitions en les remplaçant par
le culte des saints avec les reliques et
tout mais revenons à nos moutons
la sorcellerie et la divination et est
donc connue depuis longtemps est
pratiquée et ne semblait pas poser
beaucoup de problèmes jusqu'à
l'apparition des procès de sorcellerie
et même là ça ne semblait pas être à
cause du mythe du sabbat ou du démon que
les villageois ont accusé d'autres au
19e siècle de nouvelles théories
apparaissent pour les historiens
romantique comme je le mets schl et la
femme au 16e siècle est un pauvre être
dominés et persécutés il va même plus
loin il pense que le sabbat existe
réellement et qu'à force d'être traité
en boucs émissaires les femmes se
rebelle
les sorcières seraient donc des
contestataires là ça va un peu loin et
quand on voit que la plupart du temps
les femmes pendant les procès avait
l'air d'être perdue hagarde dépassés par
ce qui leur arrive et on a un peu de mal
à y croire
l'égyptologue margaret murray va encore
plus loin que michelet et pense que la
sorcellerie existait réellement qu'elle
était une survivance de culte
préchrétien comme le culte de diane
et que beaucoup de personnes y croyait
encore qu'est ce qu'on en pense
aujourd'hui que se passe-t-il réellement
dans les campagnes du xvème et xvième
siècle en même temps que la chasse aux
sorcières et bien il semblerait que la
peur des sorcières aille de pair avec la
diffusion de nouvelles idées en ville à
partir du 15e siècle et dans les
campagnes à partir du xvième siècle
l'église tente de son crée davantage
dans la vie paysanne et de remplacer les
vieilles superstitions
cela passe par l'apparition du
catéchisme et des écoles pastorale dans
lesquels on apprend l'existence du dieu
unique en opposition avec satan ou fait
donc rentrer dans la culture populaire
et ça fait peur aux enfants
ce couteau a pris à lui colle aux
critiques ont plu chez et quelle
coïncidence
les enfants dont je parlais plus tôt qui
accusent leur part en sorcellerie sont
justement ces enfants qui commencent
tout juste le catéchisme il semblerait y
avoir un lien de cause à effet et puis
ces femmes qui se prenait pour des
galets ce sacré parle de concurrence à
l'église en plus c'est elle qui
diffusait la culture populaire aux
enfants toutes les superstitions ses
croyances c'est leur faute au bûcher
allons un peu plus loin avec ce nouvel
encadrement de la société par l'église
au 16ème siècle l'âge du mariage recul
c'est frustrant parce que les groupes de
jeunes hommes célibataires qui formaient
souvent des bandes à l'époque pas très
jojo souvent violents pourraient être
tout perturbé par ça et je ne sais pas
en réaction accusé les femmes de coucher
avec le diable dans les villages où
cette nouvelle idée de la société cette
nouvelle éducation s'ancre centre
problème on n'observe pas ou très peu de
procès de sorcellerie par contre quand
ça bloque quand les paysans sont tout
perturbé qu'il trouve que c'était mieux
avant on voit des procès de sorcellerie
cette idée explique que les épisodes de
chasse aux sorcières soit souvent brefs
et localiser l'église débarque dans un
village commence à recomposer les rôles
sociaux à répondre ces nouvelles idées
d'un coup on voit des sorcières partout
l'inquisition arrive et fait le tri dans
le tas et puis bon finalement la crise
passe le village trouver un nouvel
équilibre et des accusations
disparaissent selon cette théorie qui
est plutôt répandu de nos jours la
chasse aux sorcières résulte donc d'une
mutation sociale engagée par les dons
qu'on s'est tapé d'état de procès
bûcher pour une réforme scolaire mal
foutu bravo bravo
là tu simplifie pas chemin et utilise
des références contemporaines pour
expliquer un événement lointain c'est
pas bien je peux pas le laisser faire ça
ok on fait des blagues depuis tout à
l'heure et tout à coup madame devient
sérieusement je m'en vais merci d'avoir
regarder cet épisode
je vous rappelle que si vous n'êtes pas
familier de la chaîne il existe
également un épisode sur l'inquisition
et sur le sahb qui doivent apparaître à
peu près ici vous pouvez les regarder
et si vous aimez ce que je fais une fois
n'est pas coutume je rappelle que vous
pouvez partager cette vidéo où vous
abonner et allez faire un tour sur le
tipi qui est ici et en attendant le
prochain épisode qui sera palpitant
portez vous bien et amertume des fennecs
[Musique]
la bonne cause babeau comme témoins
quatre ans